(playful instrumental music)
- [Narrator] This is
Zawadi, an African Lion.
These stunning big cats
are Africa's apex predator.
They once roamed most of Africa
and parts of Europe and Asia,
but today they are only found
in parts of Sub-Saharan Africa.
Zawadi is a male lion,
indicated by his large mane.
Lions are considered
the only social member
of the cat family, and live
in large groups called prides.
Females do most of the
hunting and work in teams,
ambushing their prey.
Their importance to the
ecosystem is paramount,
playing a key role in the food chain,
controlling herbivore populations,
but while they are the alpha predators,
they face threats of their own.
A combination of trophy
hunting and habitat loss
has cut their population in
half over the past two decades.
This is the African lion.
(gentle instrumental music)